on revient en premier sur l'actualité
dramatique de ce soir cette attaque à la
préfecture de police de paris
nous irons en direct tout au long de
l'émission en cas de déclaration sur
place à l'assemblée
une minute de silence a été observée à
15h par les députés cette la ministre de
la justice nicole belloubet qui a pris
la parole en premier je vous propose
d'écouter sa déclaration savons d'ores
et déjà que plusieurs victimes sont
malheureusement à déplorer
je voulais simplement devant vous et
avec vous assurez les victimes et leurs
familles de toutes nos pensées
je souhaiterais également dire aux
agents et hauts fonctionnaires de la
préfecture de police qu'ils peuvent être
assurés en ces circonstances extrêmement
traumatisantes et douloureuse tragique
de notre soutien le plus total
maxime des gayets soutien le plus total
bien sûr compassion évidemment mais est
ce qu'il ya un problème de sécurité dans
tout ça qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce
nouveau drame de la sidération
d'abord je pense que c'est le cas de
tout le monde parce que le bilan est
particulièrement lourd
je crois que l'on peut pour l'instant
resté que principalement là on va voir
ce que dit l'enquète après c'est aussi
un fait qui s'inscrit dans un contexte
qui est un contexte qu'on a tous en tête
qui est le malaise aujourd'hui que
rencontrent les forces de police donc
je pense qu'il faut il faudra
certainement jugé ce qui s'est passé au
regard de la réalité des faits on semble
comprendre aux gens rebuter déclaré tout
à l'heure il semblerait l'intérieur il
semblerait que ce que ce soit une qui
est un quelque chose de tragique mais
enfin qui qui qui n'a pas d'autre raison
que la folie de celui qui l'a qu'il a
fait après c'est grossier on que c'est
intervient dans un moment qui à un
moment dans lequel les forces de police
ne cessent d'exprimer leurs difficultés
de conditions de travail
quoiqu'elle ne fait que commencer
effectivement pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de présomption une enquête est en
cours une perquisition est en cours à
gonesse donc effectivement on s'en
seront plus dans les heures qui suivent
malgré tout un attaquant équipé d'un
couteau au sein la préfecture de police
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez également à alexandra vous aurais
dit c'est qu'il garde les gardes
ça reste un sujet éternel là en
l'occurrence on verra ce qu'il faut
maintenant trouver comme comme raison à
ce geste fou ce qui est certain c'est
que si l émotion est extrêmement
profonde et dans le corps de la police
cette attaque laissera aller sera
laissera une trace pour le coup
extrêmement net je pense qu'il y aura un
avant et il y aura un après c'est vrai
vous l'avez dit ça tourne à un moment
particulier intervient juste après la
manif là encore il faudra essayer de
faire attention aux amalgames de toute
façon y'a que même si là c'est vraiment
l'acte de quelqu'un qui a été un plomb à
un moment donné précis de sa vie mais
beaucoup ne pourront pas s'empêcher de
pointer le fait que de toute façon
l'absence durable de moyens l'excès le
manque de reconnaissance quasi permanent
la pression extrême à la fois de l'ain
terme et la pression extrême de la rue
de la ville de la vie tout court au
niveau du métier de policier aujourd'hui
que tout ça a peut être provoqué sans
doute provoqué cette situation de
détresse extrême et l'acte qui a été qui
a été commis alors prié peut-être
d'autres raisons personnelles ou mais en
attendant c'est sûr que ce sera ce sera
un moyen
en tout cas ça provoquera un débat sur
le commandant la durée on prend en
compte cette situation des positions
france mais c'est pas les seuls à dire
les gens qui se suicident ou des gens
qui commettent des erreurs parce qu'ils
sont arrivés à un stade extrême
malheureusement il y en a et alors dans
d'autres pays comme les etats unis
ça prend des proportions s'appelle les
turinois ça prend des proportions assez
considérable on a l'impression que chez
nous ça vient on fait toujours ce que
font les américains avec quelques années
de retard
en tout cas ça soit moi j'ai une grosse
grosse et profonde pensée pour pour pour
les policiers français un avis et un
avant et un après c'était également
votre votre avis
après les jeux hier c'était la
manifestation des policiers dans notre
pays qui parlait dans leurs conditions
de travail
terrible et en parlant en off avec
certains d'entre eux certains
responsables syndicaux
il m'avait parlé en fait de ce malaise
dans la police avec les hiérarchies
justement est le problème qu'avait des
syndicats de faire remonter ces
problèmes où chacun se couvraient un peu
avec beaucoup de népotisme beaucoup de
beaucoup de collusion et aujourd'hui
n'est pas remonté ça arrive souvent
enfin la ligne r c'était vraiment le cri
du coeur des syndicalistes est
aujourd'hui l'un d'eux mauvais message
c'est même étonnant que ça n'arrive pas
plus souvent ce genre de drame voilà
vous dire l'état de la police
aujourd'hui donc c'est un corps de
métier à cran parce qu'il ya la pression
extérieure mais aussi à la pression
intérieure il ya des graves problèmes
gérard chic et des problèmes de
management il ya des problèmes de
pression aussi sur le chiffre alors
qu'on n'est pas équipé qu'on a pas les
moyens les policiers s'achète encore
leur équipement dans les commissariats
enfin tout ça c'est une réalité donc ce
drame terrible avec ses quatre ou cinq
personnes qui perdent la vie alors s'il
doit y avoir une seule lettre d'armes de
tir et c'est revoir les conditions de
travail des policiers on va voir aussi
la façon dont sont gérées les
commissariats et laisser aller les
responsables syndicaux faire leur
trailer travail protéger les
travailleurs justement parce qu'ils sont
en première ligne parce que c'est un
boulot extrêmement difficile extrêmement
dur c'est peut être confronté quand même
à ce qu'il ya de pire dans la société de
manière quotidienne
c'est un travail social on a bien sûr en
images quelques égarements les violences
policières lors lors des manifestations
du gilet jaune mais la majorité du
travail c'est des gens qui font un
travail exceptionnel et qui le font dans
des conditions déplorables donc s'il
doit y avoir un réveil c'est celui là
marc landré c'était c'est un fervent
point même de moyens
franchement je je sais pas les d'après
les premiers éléments qui ont été
communiqués par le ministre l'intérieur
c'est quelqu'un qui avait 20 ans
d'ancienneté qui n'avait jamais fait
parler de lui au sein de la préfecture
de police qui travaille dans le centre
des renseignements visiblement des
syndicats policiers ont parlé de pétage
de plombs c'est vrai sauf que ça aurait
pu arriver dans un centre des impôts
visiblement ça aurait pu arriver dans un
hôpital ça aurait pu arriver même
ancienne entreprise parce qu un pétage
de plombs personne ne peut le prévoir
a priori et surtout on sait pas où est
ce qui peut taper donc est ce que c'est
un problème de moyens je pense qu'il
faut peut-être pas tout mélanger il ya
un problème de moyens d'aller dans la
zone à la police c'est un fait est-ce
que c'est lié est ce que cette tuerie
malheureusement est liée à ce coin de
mes moyens je ne crois qu'en la personne
et même la personne était et travaille
depuis 20 ans n'avaient jamais fait il
n'avait jamais été visiblement repéré
une personne qui était depuis 20 ans une
personne atteinte de surdité
mais oui quelques était handicapé je
ferai les handicapés et dans son
allocution très sommaire est très sobre
le miz l'intérieur disait qu'il n'avait
pas fait état il n'avait jamais rien
avec la remontée contre lui en termes
comportementale durant cet essai le
décennies malgré tout les premiers
éléments montrent que pour l'instant ils
auraient quand même jamais présenté
aucun signe d' alerte donc je sais ce
que je dis tout à fait c'est le cas
enfin vous parlez de tous les corps de
métier mais aujourd'hui c'est les
obsèques de martin annonce est
proviseur qui a mis fin à ses jours est
pareil qui avaient beaucoup d'ancienneté
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une fatigue
aussi je pense peut-être l'accumulation
toutes ces années finalement on arrive à
un moment où on demande encore davantage
comme on a vu les suicides à la poste
parce qu'on change de métier
d'une certaine façon donc il faut faire
attention il faut faire attention aux
gens qui travaillent on amènera
spécialement de manière générale oui
vous avez un problème de rapport lors
c'est sans doute pas du tout en lien
avec la problématique du jour on
apprenait de rapports entre l'autorité
politique de l'autorité policière
il ya peu quand même les policiers ont
très très souvent le rôle du fusible et
du lampiste lorsque il y a un problème
de mise en oeuvre d'une politique
publique et que sur le terrain ça ne se
passe pas bien
on oublie souvent que le premier donneur
d'ordre c'est le politique qui donne des
consignes qui après sont impliqués alors
plus ou moins bien mais souvent plutôt
bien par rapport à la consigne a été
donnée et au bout du compte qui se passe
qui se passe c'est à dire que quand ça
dérape pas c'est un commissaire qu'on
débarque c'est un capitaine qu'on
démontre quand vous avez la sphère
benalla c'est toute une série de fusible
en chaîne qui sont sanctionnés et alors
qu'ils n'ont fait qu'obéir aux si je
puis dire au souverain donc on a aussi
un problème d'ambiance au niveau de la
police en france a été dit par par
alexis poulin et cette ambiance là le
pouvoir politique a une très grosse
responsabilité sur les épaules
et encore je déconnecte d'une certaine
façon mais peut-être que malgré tout ce
pétage de plomb peut trouver aussi ses
racines dans un long et profond malaise
et vous savez parfois les gens qui se
suicident personne ne voit rien venir
alors c'est pas un suicide c'est bien
pire que çà mais c'est un peu le même
principe tout d'un coup une espèce de la
décision de se donner la mort parce
qu'il devait débuter dans cet
environnement là en faisant ce qu'ils
faisaient on n'allait pas l'accueillir
en héros à la sortie non parce qu'il ya
quand même des heures dans un mois la
préfecture de police de paris
mais cette voie là je pense que c'est il
ya peut-être malgré tout une espèce de
causalité indirect et je pense que le
politique doit vraiment s'interroger sur
sa façon si je puis dire de manager la
fonction publique et les fonctionnaires
alors sur un sur le site du figaro.fr
babineau qui est un de nos habitués nous
dit c'est un peu tôt pour remettre en
cause la sécurité c'est une tragédie
mais on ne peut pas anticiper un coup de
folie
nicole peut-on considérer que l'acte
était prémédité puisqu'il avait un
couteau en céramique donc fait pour être
indétectable je crois qu'on peut
on peut considérer en effet que l'acte
était prémédité je ne vois pas trop ce
que les moyens vient de faire là dedans
nous disent itx dans tous les cas nous
reviendrons nous suivrons ce drame de
très près et tout au long de